for us chemical engineers learning
stigma is almost necessary to survive in
the industry after all you cannot
compromise on quality
when i realize it i immediately chose a
course from simply learn which
ultimately helped me boost my career
with a twenty percent salary high
hi my name is marika milayakono i am 28
years old i am a chemical engineer
living in new jersey
new york is a hub of opportunities and
working here was always my dream
so when i got a job opportunity here i
took it without thinking twice and i
work really hard for it
[Music]
i was living and working in philadelphia
when the pandemic hit
i was working with sugar right as a
chemical engineer and in august 2020 i
left my job due to some personal reasons
i was free and i decided to utilize my
time to learn a new skill and i went for
the lean six sigma green belt
certification from simply there within
the certification there was a sub
certification called lean management
which i completed in december 2020. it
was really helpful
in january 2021 i was hired by a leading
cosmetic company as a chemical engineer
with a 20
salary height i shifted to new jersey
and started working in new york i
completed my certification in march
2021. even at my job here i am applying
my learnings from the course regularly
in fact we have problems with organizing
the space since so many new products
were coming in so i used 5s which is a
japanese way of sorting things out to
organize things at my work it is
something i learned during the course it
has helped me a lot
i am really happy with the kind of life
that i'm living right now i am having
the time of my life
you